some good news at last for yes bank
customers nearly two weeks after the
government took over India's fourth
largest private lender the withdrawal
limit of fifty thousand rupees or six
hundred and thirty dollars imposed
during the government takeover is due to
end on Wednesday I was quite fearful
because he eats like it's a hard-earned
money and we are just putting all our
savings one particular bank so that's
not easy for the working class people
and hopefully we I mean we work
efficiently waiting for some positive
response so and this response was quite
quick I believe the government took
control on March the 6th because the
bank had too many bad debts and loans
which weren't being repaid the takeover
led to worry customers lining up to get
their money out and the government
imposing the withdrawal limit for the
bailout the government of the Reserve
Bank of India brought together eight
banks led by the State Bank of India the
largest in the country
the failure of yes Bank is again
highlighting the banking crisis involved
in financial institutions with too many
bad loans shadow banks which don't face
the same regulations as well-known
lenders and over indebted companies
yes banks customers included some of
India's biggest businesses including the
annie'll Ambani group Ambani was once
one of India's richest people
incremental big increase in credit was
going to already promoters word who were
in default or near default who were not
able to pay back their bank loans taken
much earlier like in the UPA in the
previous regime right so so that's what
it turns out all the cronies ended up
getting more loans to pay back their
earlier loans the government has accused
yes banks founder Rana Kapoor and his
family of laundering around six hundred
million dollars by receiving kickbacks
for extending loans that couldn't be
repaid
Kapoor's lawyer says he's being made a
scapegoat fifth largest private analysts
say the toxic loans crisis ago was
beyond a few bad apples it's the third
time in a year that India's Reserve Bank
has intervened to rescue a lender the
way our bad loans have
have plagued our economy our financial
system the last five years
both are behind government had been
hoping for a slow train wreck you know
they want to soft land the problem so
they were they were looking away but in
this business there is no slow train
wreck a train wreck is a train wreck it
will cause damage many are asking why
the government didn't notice yes bank's
massive growth when the economy was
suffering a significant slowdown
yes banks rescue comes at a bad time for
India's economy which is growing at its
slowest pace in over six years the
government is now investigating why this
takeover had to happen the financial
analysts say unless the entire sector is
reformed Asia's third biggest economy
could deteriorate further Elizabeth
puranam al-jazeera New Delhi